Tasha: 还有一个手套能拿给我一下吗
Tasha: Can someone hand me another glove?
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Lucia: 哎这好像不是手套
Lucia: Oh, this doesn’t seem like a glove.
Jake:你小心点啊小心
Jake: Be careful, be careful.
Jake: 小心十分小心
Jake: Be very careful.
Lucia: 是那个厚的是吧
Lucia: The thick one, right?
Jake: 齐的是吧
Jake: Is it the matching one?
Tasha: 算了算了
Tasha: Nevermind, nevermind.
Lucia: 找到了
Lucia: Found it.
Jake: 穿过来了
Jake: Got it through.
Jake: 然后我们这边还有多久
Jake: How much longer for us over here?
Jake: 大概
Jake: About...
Jake: 大概大概还有几分钟呀
Jake: About how many more minutes?
Tasha: 五分钟五分钟
Tasha: Five minutes, five minutes.
Jake:五分钟好
Jake: Five minutes, okay.
Jake: 哈五分钟之后把这个端上去
Jake: Okay, in five minutes, bring this up.
Jake: 然后上面我直接开了就好
Jake: Then I'll just open it up there.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 然后五分钟我
Jake: In five minutes, I'll...
Jake: 就这基本放视频吧
Jake: Let's just put the video there.
其他人：喂哎
Others: Hey
Shure:  是可以走流程了吗
Jake: 可以走流程了
其他人：好的
Others: Okay
其他人：Let's welcome our  big boss   YANG
Others: Let's welcome our big boss Jake
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 为什么big boss
Jake: Why big boss?
Shure:  big boss
Shure: Big boss
Jake: big boss
Jake: Big boss
其他人：:不是第一个boss
Jake: 好嘞好嘞好
Jake: Alright, alright
Jake: 欢迎大家
Jake: Welcome everyone
Jake: 欢迎
Jake: Welcome
Jake: 志愿者的朋友们
Jake: Friends of the volunteers
Jake: 是吧那个远道而来
Jake: It's not easy, right?
Jake: 很不容易
Jake: It's not easy
Jake: 这个地方很偏
Jake: This place is remote
Jake: 我们原来
Jake: We originally
Jake: 这个在整个北京的范围内
Jake: Chose this villa within Beijing
Jake: 选了一个
Jake: Chose a
Jake: 最靠近北京市中心的一个别墅
Jake: One closest to the city center
Jake: 就在这个地方
Jake: It's right here
Jake: 但是但还是很欢迎大家可以过来吧
Jake: But still, we're very glad you could come
Jake: 啊我们啊
Jake: Ah, we
Jake: 可能大家也都有听有所听说
Jake: Maybe you've all heard
Jake: 就是我们这个项目呢
Jake: About our project
Jake: 它就是一个叫ego life的一个项目
Jake: It's called Ego Life
Jake: 它恩
Jake: So, um
Jake: 你你们也看到了
Jake: You can see
Jake: 我们每人戴一个奇怪的眼镜
Jake: We're all wearing strange glasses
Jake: 然后一圈都是摄像头对吧
Jake: And there are cameras all around, right?
Jake: 然后这是为什么呢
Jake: So, why is that?
Jake: 这是我们要采集一个第一视角的数据
Jake: We're collecting first-person view data
Jake: 和一个第三视角的数据
Jake: And third-person view data
Jake: 这边有8个摄像头
Jake: There are 8 cameras here
Jake: 这边有7个摄像头
Jake: 7 cameras here
Jake: 楼下有6
Jake: 6 downstairs
Jake: 这楼下有8个
Jake: 8 downstairs
Jake: 然后每人有有一个
Jake: And everyone has one
Jake: 你这个电就没了
Jake: Your battery just died
Jake: 如果大伙看到我们志愿者
Jake: If everyone sees our volunteers
Jake: 有人这个眼睛上面的灯不亮了
Jake: Someone's light above their eyes isn't on.
Jake: 就要告诉他
Jake: You have to tell them.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 我就是给大家做一个示范
Jake: I'm just giving everyone a demonstration.
Shure:  这都是设计好的
Shure: This was all designed.
Jake: 对这都是设计好的
Jake: Yes, this was all designed.
Shure:  它刚刚不亮是吧
Shure: It wasn't on just now, right?
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 我们收集这个第一视角视频呢
Jake: We're collecting this first-person perspective video.
Jake: 就是为了去做分析
Jake: It's for analysis.
Jake: 分析我们大概一周啊这些人啊
Jake: To analyze what these people are doing for about a week.
Jake: 都在干什么
Jake: What are they doing.
Jake: 然后为今天呃形成一个一天的日记啊
Jake: Then today, uh, we'll form a one-day diary.
Jake: 然后第二天的一些plan啊
Jake: Then plan for the next day.
Jake: 大概这些任务
Jake: These tasks roughly.
Jake: 当然这些都不重要
Jake: Of course, these are not important.
Jake: 我们重要的是
Jake: What’s important is.
Jake: 我们欢迎各位来参加我们今天earth day
Jake: We welcome everyone to join our Earth Day.
Jake: weekend的这个活动
Jake: Weekend activity.
Jake: 好谢谢大家
Jake: Okay, thank you all.
Jake: 然后
Jake: Then.
Jake: 没有我们先切出去
Jake: No, let's cut out first.
Shure: 我们先切出去
Shure: Let's cut out first.
Jake: 我们先切出去
Jake: Let's cut out first.
Jake: 我们要
Jake: We need to.
Jake: 我靠 这么难切
Jake: Damn, it's so hard to cut.
Jake: 我要切到另一个屏
Jake: I need to cut to another screen.
Jake:哦他没有其他频
Jake: Oh, there's no other screen.
Jake:没有其他频就在这
Jake: There's no other screen, it's just here.
Jake: 这个就是我在
Jake: This is what I.
Jake: 这个是我们
Jake: This is our.
Jake: 啊一个记录小纪录片
Jake: Uh, a small documentary.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 一个
Jake: A.
Jake: 未完片的纪录片
Jake: An unfinished documentary.
Jake: 我们在
Jake: We are.
Jake: 我们这个项目呢
Jake: This project of ours.
Jake: 是4月13号
Jake: On April 13th.
Jake: 我们见到的第一位志愿者刘雨萱同学
Jake: We met our first volunteer, Liu Yuxuan.
Jake: 在北京几站
Jake: How many stops in Beijing?
Jake: 西站
Jake: West Station.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 北京西站
Jake: Beijing West Station.
Jake: 她拿到了这个眼镜
Jake: She got these glasses.
Jake: 我们也用了我们的小包
Jake: We also used our small bag.
Jake: 去欢迎他抵达北京
Jake: To welcome her to Beijing.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 刘雨萱第一天很开心的样子
Jake: Liu Yuxuan seemed very happy on the first day.
Jake: 戴上眼镜之后就不太开心了
Jake: But after putting on the glasses, she seemed less happy.
Jake: 看起来 哈哈哈
Jake: Looks like it, haha.
Jake: 强装开心呵呵
Jake: Pretending to be happy, haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 然后我们第二位嘉宾Lucia还在楼下
Jake: And our second guest, Lucia, is still downstairs.
Jake: 是在北京首都机场
Jake: At Beijing Capital Airport.
Jake: 我们两位同学
Jake: Our two classmates.
Jake: 在绝味鸭脖前进行了会晤
Jake: Met in front of the Juewei Duck Neck shop.
Jake: 进行了会晤
Jake: They met up.
Shure:  会晤你看这词用的就好
Shure: "Met up", that's a good word choice.
Jake: 那是
Jake: Of course.
Jake: 进行了一些简单的眼睛教导
Jake: Gave some simple instructions on the glasses.
Jake: 比如说这个眼睛亮灯
Jake: Like, the glasses light up.
Jake: 才能使用
Jake: Then you can use them.
Jake: 大家可能意识到这个背景音乐啊
Jake: Everyone might notice the background music.
Jake: 可能也没有意识到这个背景音乐了
Jake: Or maybe they didn't notice the background music.
Jake: 他是solo AI生存的这个title
Jake: It's the title of the solo AI survival project.
Jake: 这个title
Jake: This title.
Jake: 他他的这个名字叫ego life
Jake: Its name is "Ego Life".
Jake: 是我们的project name
Jake: It's our project name.
Jake: 大家可以注意一下这个
Jake: Everyone can pay attention to it.
Jake: 一些歌词是用到了
Jake: Some of the lyrics are used.
Jake: 我们就是都
Jake: They are all.
Jake: 都是我们内部的一些梗
Jake: Inside jokes among us.
Jake: 有些人可能知道
Jake: Some people might know.
Jake: 对这个人
Jake: This person.
Jake: 秀儿哎
Jake: Shure, hey.
Jake: 秀儿已经过去了
Jake: Shure has passed.
Jake: 因为这个秀儿这个镜头没有被捡到
Jake: Because this Shure shot wasn't picked up.
Jake: 原因是
Jake: The reason is.
Jake: 没时间了哈哈哈
Jake: There's no time, hahaha.
Shure:  哎呀哎呀哎呀
Shure: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake: 好欢迎大家来到我们的ego
Jake: Alright, welcome everyone to our ego.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 啊我们
Jake: Uh, we...
Jake: 刚刚
Jake: Just now...
Jake:啊  应该是
Jake: Ah, it should be...
Jake: 尚柯欣我也没有时间剪
Jake: I didn't have time to edit.
Jake: 所以不好意思
Jake: So, sorry about that.
Jake: 她还没来
Jake: She's not here yet.
Jake: 还在楼下
Jake: Still downstairs.
Jake: 但是没关系
Jake: But it's okay.
Jake: 回头再剪好
Jake: We'll edit it later.
Shure:  好我们进入正题
Shure: Alright, let's get to the main topic.
Jake: 我们来进入正题
Jake: Let's get to the main topic.
Jake: 今天呢我们原计划
Jake: Today, our original plan was...
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 如果一切都很顺利的话
Jake: If everything goes smoothly...
Jake: 是这么个时间线
Jake: It's this kind of timeline.
Jake: 但是自然而然的很不顺利
Jake: But naturally, things didn't go smoothly.
Jake: 就是但是我们就往后顺延对吧
Jake: So, we'll just postpone it, right?
Jake: 现改现在是几点
Jake: What time is it now?
Jake: 我们来现改
Jake: Let's check the time.
Jake:4点
Jake: 4 o'clock.
Jake: 4月07 4月07 好
Jake: April 7th, April 7th, okay.
Jake: 4点07
Jake: 4:07.
Jake: 我们进行到了introduction的一半的部分
Jake: We're halfway through the introduction part.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈现改真的是
Jake: Hahahaha, live editing, really.
Shure:  其他不重要
Shure: The rest doesn't matter.
Shure:  star time对了
Shure: The start time is right.
Shure:  咱们就OK了
Shure: We're good.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  你看看
Shure: Look.
Shure:  我们精准的控制到4.07
Shure: We precisely controlled it to 4:07.
Shure:  来进行我们的introduction部分
Shure: To do our introduction part.
Jake: 好 再过哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Alright, and then...hahahahahaha.
其他人：再过20
Others: In another 20...
Jake: 再过20多小时之后
Jake: In another 20 plus hours.
Jake: 我们就结束了今天的introduction
Jake: We'll finish today's introduction.
Jake: 啊 然后下面我们会进行一些啊
Jake: Ah, next we will do some, ah...
Jake: 因为我们这7天前
Jake: Because 7 days ago...
Jake: 前6天我们让每个志愿者
Jake: For the first 6 days, we had each volunteer...
Jake: 都装饰了自己的房间
Jake: Decorate their own room...
Jake: 装饰成了
Jake: Decorated it...
Jake: 一个主题来
Jake: With a theme...
Jake: 和这个ego earth
Jake: To correspond with ego earth...
Jake: 和这个earth day做一个呼应
Jake: And Earth Day.
Jake: 然后我们就很期待
Jake: So we're really looking forward...
Jake: 各位志愿者的小屋装
Jake: To seeing how each volunteer's room...
Jake: 装饰成了什么样子
Jake: Turned out.
Jake: 对然后一会我们就会进行一个参观
Jake: Yes, and in a bit, we'll have a tour...
Jake: 然后参观之后呢
Jake: And after the tour...
Lucia: 贴了一个小组的海报
Lucia: We put up a group poster.
Jake: 我们会有一个QA的环节
Jake: We'll have a Q&A session.
Jake: 呃如果早来的观众呢
Jake: For those early attendees...
Jake: 你们可能会经历一个找
Jake: You might experience a scavenger hunt...
Jake: 找这个ego币的一个环节
Jake: To find ego coins.
Jake: 就是可能在一楼啊
Jake: There might be some hidden stickers...
Jake: 二楼啊会有一些藏着的小贴画
Jake: On the first or second floor.
Jake: 呃如果找到的话
Jake: If you find them...
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 下面会有一个auction
Jake: Will have an auction...
Jake: auction就是拍卖
Jake: Auction means bidding.
Jake:  我们会有一些小商品和
Jake: We will have some small items and...
Jake: 这个可能各位客人也会带来一些
Jake: Maybe guests might bring some small trinkets...
Jake: 小物件
Jake: Items...
Jake: 然后我们进行一个拍卖
Jake: That we'll auction off.
Jake: 就用我们发售的这个
Jake: Using the ego Coin we've issued...
Jake: ego Coin已经上链了
Jake: Which is already on the blockchain.
Jake: 对这个十年
Jake: Yes, in ten years...
Jake: 这个十年
Jake: In ten years...
Jake: 大家保存好这个
Jake: Keep your ego Coin...
Jake: ego Coin
Jake: You might achieve financial freedom...
Jake: 可能过十年之后大家就财富自由
Jake: In ten years. Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈OK
Jake: Hahahahaha, okay.
Jake: 呃按照原计划5点半
Jake: According to the original plan, 5:30...
Jake: 但是现在不知道是什么时候
Jake: But now, who knows what time it is...
Jake: 这个不重要
Jake: It doesn't matter...
Jake: 就是我们就会进行啊
Jake: We will proceed with...
Jake: 到了party time
Jake: It's party time
Jake: 就是吃吃喝喝
Jake: Just eating and drinking
Jake: 玩玩乐乐
Jake: Having fun
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright
Jake: 会有一些音乐活动
Jake: There will be some music activities
Jake: 大家也知道
Jake: Everyone knows
Jake: 我们在看到这个阵仗特别的强势
Jake: We see this setup is quite strong
Jake: 那我们来进行
Jake: So let's proceed
Jake: 这个就不管他了
Jake: We'll just ignore that
Jake: 这个ego coin就是我们
Jake: This ego coin is our
Jake: 就是大家记好这个
Jake: Just remember this
Jake: 这个标就是如有雷同就是假的
Jake: This label, if it looks the same, it's fake
Jake: 就不要买
Jake: Don't buy it
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 这个我们可能先
Jake: We might first
Jake: 我们先进行room tour
Jake: Let's do a room tour first
Jake: room tour的活动吗
Jake: Room tour activity?
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or
Lucia: 你们先进行
Lucia: You guys go first
Lucia: 这个我要进去收一下
Lucia: I need to tidy up a bit
Jake: 你要先进行啊
Jake: You need to go first?
Jake: 你要先收一下
Jake: You need to tidy up first
Jake: 那我们先进行QA的活动
Jake: Then we'll do the QA activity first
Jake: 好一切都在我们的掌控之中
Jake: Okay, everything is under our control
Jake: 一切都在计划之中
Jake: Everything is according to plan
Shure:  就我们这个项目只有一位
Shure: In this project, there's only one
Shure:  只有一位是这人
Shure: Only one person
Shure:  然后就是她
Shure: And that's her
Shure:  就是计划
Shure: She's the planner
Shure:  非常的中意
Shure: She's very into it
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Jake: 她对计划担当
Jake: She's in charge of the plan
Jake: 我们可以
Jake: We can
Jake: 那趁她在装饰的时候
Jake: While she's decorating
Jake: 我们可能可以再去看一下这个小影片
Jake: We might as well watch a short video
Jake: 里边有一些
Jake: Inside, there are
Jake: 一些可以回味的地方
Jake: Some memorable moments
Shure:  回味的地方
Shure: Memorable moments
Alice: 还有盘吗
Alice: Are there any more plates?
Jake:哪儿去了
Jake: Where did they go?
Shure:  这个
Shure: This one.
Shure:  回味一下
Shure: Savor it for a moment.
Jake: 刚刚那个架子呢
Jake: Where's that rack we had?
Jake: 就是每天8点了
Jake: It's already 8 o'clock every day.
Jake: 我们的Katrina
Jake: Our Katrina.
Jake: 那个架子
Jake: That rack.
Jake: Katrina同学
Jake: Katrina, our classmate.
Jake: 她就会叫我们起床
Jake: She wakes us up.
Jake: 我们的J人同学会叫我们起床
Jake: Our classmate J wakes us up.
Jake: 是吧j人
Jake: Right, J?
Shure:  她叫
Shure: She does.
Jake: 对古希腊掌管
Jake: Yes, like the ancient Greek god.
Jake: 掌管闹钟的神
Jake: The god of alarm clocks.
Shure:  她的闹钟会准时的把我叫醒
Shure: Her alarm clock wakes me up on time.
其他人：意思就是别人都叫不醒
Others: Meaning no one else can wake you.
Jake: 是的
Jake: Exactly.
Shure:  然后
Shure: And then...
Jake: 这是主歌
Jake: This is the verse.
Jake: 这个这是副歌
Jake: And this is the chorus.
Jake: 副歌就没有什么意义
Jake: The chorus doesn't mean much.
Jake: 这就是AI写的了
Jake: This part is written by AI.
Jake: 我们也听不看不懂也听不懂
Jake: We can't understand or make sense of it.
Jake: 啊这就是你啊这是
Jake: Ah, this is you.
Jake: 就是这个歌词是你
Jake: These lyrics are you.
Jake: 虽然人不是你 就是
Jake: Even though the person isn't you.
Jake: 人 supposed to be me
Jake: The person supposed to be me.
Shure: supposed to be me 对 OK
Shure: Supposed to be me, right. OK.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 就是他是我们的鼓手
Jake: He's our drummer.
Jake: 对你你介绍一下吧
Jake: Yes, introduce yourself.
Jake: 你是谁啊
Jake: Who are you?
Shure:  我我我我是一个
Shure:  混子
Shure: A bum.
Shure:  混子鼓手
Shure: A bum drummer.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  就是
Shure: Just...
Shure:  在在这个大家庭里充当一些氛围担当
Shure: Playing the role of the mood setter in this big family.
Shure:  就是没事给大家清晨嚎一嗓子
Shure: Sometimes giving everyone a morning shout.
Shure:  京剧什么的
Shure: Peking opera and stuff
Shure:  对就是叫大家起床
Shure: Yeah, just to wake everyone up
Shure:  大概是小百灵是吧
Shure: It's probably a little lark, right?
其他人：闹钟闹完叫不醒就你
Others: If an alarm can't wake you up, it's just you
Shure:  这个小黄毛是我们的谢斌竹同学
Shure: This blond guy here is our classmate Xie Binzhu
Jake: 对这位这位同学
Jake: Yes, this student here
Jake: 红衣服的同学
Jake: The one in red clothes
Shure:  他是一个不良少年
Shure: He used to be a delinquent
Shure:  但是被我们的项目给改造好了
Shure: But our program has reformed him
Shure:  这就是我们ego life的魅力
Shure: That's the charm of our Ego Life program
Shure:  你看看他
Shure: Look at him
Shure:  他  曾经从来没有露出过这么灿烂的笑容
Shure: He never used to smile so brightly
Shure:  好了这段就不用看了
Shure: Alright, you don't need to watch this part
Shure:  对对对这段就可以不用看了
Shure: Yeah, yeah, you can skip this part
Shure:  想看的话
Shure: If you want to watch
Shure:  我一会贴脸给大家每人看一遍好吗
Shure: I'll show it to each of you up close later, okay?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 如果想看的同学
Jake: If anyone wants to see
Jake: 我们可以现场给他表演一遍
Jake: We can perform it live for them
Jake: 我们6个人的眼镜都在哈哈
Jake: All six of us have glasses on, haha
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright
Jake: 我们现在欢迎我们的志愿者Lucia
Jake: Now let's welcome our volunteer, Lucia
Jake: 哈喽Lucia
Jake: Hello, Lucia
Lucia: 谢谢大家
Lucia: Thank you, everyone
Lucia: 我是不是我傻
Lucia: Am I stupid?
Lucia: 我要去现在是干嘛啊
Lucia: What am I supposed to do now?
Jake:好呃
Jake: Well, um
Lucia: 好呃我是去收拾还是去怎么样可以
Lucia: Should I clean up or what?
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure
Jake: 对稍微收拾一下然后就稍微tour一下
Jake: Yeah, tidy up a bit and then take a quick tour
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay
Lucia: 好好好
Lucia: Alright, alright
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah
Shure:  那我们先tour什么
Shure: So what should we tour first?
Jake: 呃我们还是先QA吧
Jake: Uh, let's start with the Q&A
Jake: 一切都在掌握之中么
Jake: Everything under control?
Shure:  好的
Shure: Got it
Jake: 对
Jake: Yep
Jake: 那下面两位
Jake: And now, these two
Jake: 她们
Jake: They
Jake: 她们来了
Jake: They're here.
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Really?
Jake: 那我们欢迎
Jake: Let's welcome them.
Jake: 尚柯欣同学和张夏梦微同学
Jake: Shangkexin and Zhang Xiamengwei.
Jake: 要不坐
Jake: How about sitting down?
Jake: 坐找个地坐吧
Jake: Find a place to sit.
Alice: 我们能坐这吗
Alice: Can we sit here?
Jake: 当然可以好的
Jake: Of course, sure.
Alice: 好的
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 能坐这吗
Alice: Can we sit here?
Jake: 坐坐坐
Jake: Sit, sit, sit.
Alice: 太靠前了
Alice: It's too close to the front.
Jake: 再再去到Tasha那一段吧
Jake: Go to Tasha's part now.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 到Tasha这一段
Jake: To Tasha's part.
Jake: Tasha
Jake: Tasha.
Shure:  给大家看一遍Tasha的部分
Shure: Show everyone Tasha's part.
Jake: 对对看一遍Tasha的歌词
Jake: Yeah, show Tasha's lyrics.
Jake: 看一遍Tasha的歌词
Jake: Show Tasha's lyrics.
Jake: 因为给他介绍一下她的这个小
Jake: Just to introduce her little...
Jake: 小甜点
Jake: ...dessert.
Shure:  Tasha的部分在哪
Shure: Where's Tasha's part?
Jake: 我也不知道在哪就大概
Jake: I don't know, just roughly...
Jake: 可能在这吧
Jake: Maybe here?
Jake: 啊这是修是吧
Jake: Ah, this is Shure, right?
Shure:  修 修的下面
Shure: Shure, below Shure.
Jake: 修下面就是他
Jake: Below Shure is his part.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  啊我们的Tasha
Shure: Ah, our Tasha.
Jake:我们的Tasha
Jake: Our Tasha.
Shure:  也就是我们今天所有甜点的
Shure: She is the chef of all the desserts today.
Shure:  甜点的厨师
Shure: She's our head pastry chef.
Shure:  就是我们的首席甜点师
Shure: And she was introduced in the lyrics earlier, right?
Shure:    然后刚刚在歌词里介绍了一下对
Shure: Yeah, introduced in the lyrics.
Jake: 对在歌词里介绍
Jake: Yeah, introduced in the lyrics.
Jake: 现在是介绍Alice是吧
Jake: Now we're introducing Alice, right?
Jake: 是吧 人呢Alice
Jake: Right? Where's Alice?
Shure:  Alice跑了
Shure: Alice ran away.
Shure:  Alice梦游仙境去了啊
Shure: Alice went to Wonderland, huh?
Alice:  在这呢
Alice: I'm here.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Jake: 好好好好
Jake: Alright, alright, alright, alright
Jake: 介绍介绍完了
Jake: Introduction finished
Jake: 那我们来QA
Jake: Now let's do the Q&A
Shure:  还回到QA吧
Shure: Let's go back to the Q&A
Jake: 来进行到QA 2024运动会
Jake: Let's proceed to the Q&A for the 2024 Games
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈 稍有串戏
Jake: Hahaha, slight mix-up there
Jake: 那我们
Jake: So, let's
Jake: 有一个给观众的回答问题时间的环节
Jake: We have a segment where the audience can ask questions
Jake: 如果答对抢答的环节
Jake: If you answer correctly in the rapid-fire round
Jake: 抢答对的话就会拿到一个ego币
Jake: If you get it right, you'll earn an ego coin
Jake: 这个ego币可以用来换取甜品
Jake: This ego coin can be exchanged for desserts
Jake: 和为未来财富自由做准备
Jake: And to prepare for future financial freedom
Jake: 现在现在一个币每一个的价格是
Jake: Right now, each coin is priced at
Jake: 现在是多少钱
Jake: What's the current price?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Uh
Shure:  3块钱
Shure: 3 RMB
Jake: 3块人民币
Jake: 3 RMB
Jake: 好嘞现在每个一个币3块人民币
Jake: Okay, each coin is now 3 RMB
Jake: 然后明天明天我们再看看多少钱
Jake: And tomorrow, we'll see what the price is
Jake: 那我们第0题
Jake: So, our first question
Jake: 世界地球日是哪一天
Jake: When is Earth Day?
Jake: 你你举什么手
Jake: Why are you raising your hand?
Jake: 我们
Jake: We
Jake: 我们得抢
Jake: We need to buzz in
Jake: 拿怎么抢呢
Jake: How do we buzz in?
Shure:  抢举手吗
Shure: By raising our hand?
Jake: 举手那好
Jake: Raising hand, okay
Shure:  白衣少年
Shure: The guy in white
Shure:  他选择了2B
Shure: He chose 2B
Shure:  2B
Shure: 2B
Shure:  杨老板正确吗
Shure: Jake, is that correct?
Jake: 我觉得挺对的
Jake: I think it's right
Shure:  你觉得挺对的
Shure: You think it's right
Shure:  那你觉得这题应该值几个ego币
Shure: How many ego coins do you think this question is worth?
Jake:我觉得可能不太值
Jake: I think maybe not much
Jake: 因为他是地0题
Jake: Because it's the first question
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Jake: 啊这是一个热身
Jake: Ah, it's just a warm-up
Shure:  热身
Shure: A warm-up
Jake: 来让大家知道怎么举手
Jake: Let’s show everyone how to raise their hand.
Shure:  但是我觉得
Shure: But I think...
Shure:  第一个回答问题的同学勇气可嘉
Shure: The first student to answer the question is really brave.
Shure:  我们应该发出支持一下发出ego币
Shure: We should give them some support and issue an ego coin.
Jake: 好
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 支持一下
Jake: Let’s support them.
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Jake: 领了我们的第一个ego币
Jake: Claim our first ego coin.
Shure:  我们的第一个ego币
Shure: Our first ego coin.
Shure:  军事项链
Shure: Military chain.
Shure:  然后大家那个活动结束
Shure: And then after the event ends...
Shure:  可以找谢斌竹同学
Shure: You can find Xie Binzhu.
Shure:  兑换到自己的那个Mata Max的钱包里面
Shure: To exchange it into your Mata Max wallet.
Shure:  然后下一题
Shure: Alright, next question.
Shure:  首次庆祝世界地球日是哪一年
Shure: In which year was the first Earth Day celebrated?
Shure:  a 1960年
Shure: a. 1960
Shure:  b 1970年
Shure: b. 1970
Shure:  c 1980年
Shure: c. 1980
Shure:  d 2024年
Shure: In 2024.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 选b
Jake: Choose B.
Shure:  他选择二b
Shure: He chose B.
Shure:  还有哪位同学有不同意见呢
Shure: Does anyone else have a different opinion?
Shure:  白毛同学放手
Shure: Let go, White-haired student.
其他人：二 选b
Others: B, choose B.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈勇气可嘉
Jake: Hahahahaha, that’s brave of you.
Shure:  他选择的这个日子
Shure: The date he chose...
Shure:  就是那种班级倒数第一同学看一眼
Shure: It's like the answer that the last in class would pick.
Shure:  题都不会选的答案
Shure: The one who doesn't know the questions.
Shure:  还有还有同学吗
Shure: Anyone else?
其他人：我选c
Others: I'll choose C.
Shure:  你选c是吧
Shure: You choose C, right?
Alice: 刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
其他人： 干啥
Others: What?
Alice: 举手
Alice: Raise your hand.
其他人：我选a
Others: I choose A.
Shure:  看来我们的这个选项非常的焦灼大家
Shure: Looks like our choices are really close, everyone.
Shure:  大家难分伯仲
Shure: It's a tough call for everyone.
Shure:  只能说那我们公布一下正确答案
Shure: Let's just reveal the correct answer.
Jake: 我查一下哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Let me check, hahaha.
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 选B选B哈哈哈哈
Jake: Choose B, choose B, hahaha.
Jake: 选b选b
Jake: Choose B, choose B.
Jake: 1970年
Jake: 1970.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure:  又是这位又是白衣少年
Shure: It's him again, the boy in white.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 请
Jake: Please.
Tasha: : 每次那个B都是迷惑性最强的那个
其他人：是这样的
Others: That's true.
Shure:  第二题谁是世界地球日的创始人
Shure: Second question, who is the founder of Earth Day?
Shure:  A艾尔伯特爱因斯坦
Shure: A. Albert Einstein.
Shure:  B盖盖
Shure: B. Gaylord Nelson.
Shure:  盖诺特尼德尼尔森
Shure: Gaylord Anton Nelson.
Shure:  C修硕
Shure: C. Shure.
Shure:  D尚柯欣
Shure: D. John McConnell.
Jake: 谁举手快啊
Jake: Who raised their hand first?
Jake: 你看出来吗
Jake: Can you see it?
Shure:  我我感觉相机小哥你最你最快这次
Shure: I feel the camera guy, you were the fastest this time.
其他人：那要不我看大家都很喜欢B那就B
Others: Well, if everyone likes B, then let's go with B.
Shure:  他选择了B
Shure: He chose B.
Jake: 还有还有没有
Jake: Any other choices?
Shure:  还有不同答案吗
Katrina: 我选D
Katrina: I choose D.
Shure: D
Shure: D.
其他人：众所周知3   所以我选C
Others: As everyone knows, so I choose C.
其他人： 好选择
Others: Good choice.
Shure:  那个白白衣少年
Shure: That boy in white.
Shure:  啊好的好的
Shure: Ah, okay, okay.
Shure:  那我们
Shure: So we...
Shure:  想必大家已经知道
Shure: I believe everyone already knows
Shure:  这个正确答案是什么了吧
Shure: what the correct answer is, right?
Shure:  选择
Shure: Choice...
Alice: D
Alice: D.
Jake: C
Jake: C.
Shure:   选择B其实
Shure: Actually, choosing B...
Alice: D
Alice: D.
Jake:唉
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  给大家科普一下
Shure: Let me explain to everyone.
Shure:  这个盖洛德尼尔森
Shure: It was Gaylord Nelson.
Shure:  大家可能不知道他是谁吧
Shure: You guys might not know who he is.
Shure:  他是这个世界地球日的创始人
Shure: He is the founder of Earth Day.
Jake: 沙雕
Shure:  好的那个
Shure: Alright then,
Shure:  这这个题我觉得难度系数非常的大
Shure: I think this question is really difficult.
Shure:  需要奖励两个币子来同学
Shure: We should reward two coins to the student.
Shure:  但鉴于刚刚那个
Shure: But considering just now,
Shure:  选择D选项的同学
Shure: the student who chose option D,
Shure:  勇气非常可嘉
Shure: showed great courage.
Shure:  我觉得也应该奖励一枚
Shure: I think they deserve a coin too.
Katrina: 谢谢我的荣幸我的荣幸
Katrina: Thank you, it's my honor, it's my honor.
Shure:  选C选项那个就是
Shure: The answer to option C is...
Shure:  就是大葱
Shure: It's green onion.
Shure:  后面同学把嘴闭上
Shure: Everyone in the back, keep quiet.
Jake: 你还有电吗
Jake: Do you still have power?
Jake:哈哈哈哈刚充上
Jake: Haha, I just plugged it in.
其他人：刚刚已经讨论过为什么没有电了
Others: We already discussed why there's no power.
Jake: 哪个重要的政府机构
Jake: Which important government agency
Shure:  是在第一个世界地球日后成立的
Shure: was established after the first Earth Day?
Jake:又没充上
Jake: It didn't charge again.
Shure:  A国家公园管理局
Shure: A) National Park Service
Shure:  B美国农业局
Shure: B) U.S. Department of Agriculture
Shure:  C美国环境保护局
Shure: C) Environmental Protection Agency
Shure:  D美国鱼类和野生动物服务局
Shure: D) U.S. Fish and Wildlife Service
其他人：选C吧
Others: Let's choose C.
Shure:  选C还有不同答案吗
Shure: Choosing C, any different answers?
Shure:  选最长是吗
Shure: Choosing the longest one, right?
Shure:  OK选D
Shure: OK, let's choose D.
Shure:  还有其他答案吗
Shure: Any other answers?
其他人：第二个
Others: The second one.
Shure:  他选了B
Shure: He chose B.
Alice: 选A
Alice: Choosing A.
Shure:  你你不要参加回答
Shure: No, you don't get to answer.
Alice: 我不在范围啊
Alice: I'm not in the range, right?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  要不这位同学你选一下
Shure: Alright, this student, please choose one.
Shure:  好公布一下正确答案吧
Shure: Alright, let's reveal the correct answer.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 美国环境保护局
Jake: The Environmental Protection Agency.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  我觉得这题也值
Shure: I think this question is also worth it.
Jake: 确实太难了
Jake: It really is too hard.
Shure:  两个币
Shure: Two coins.
Alice: 很快你就可以赎走我了
Alice: Soon you can redeem me.
其他人：我俩我合俩合资
Others: We will invest together.
Shure:  然后下面第四题
Shure: Now, the fourth question.
Shure:  大约有多少人参加的
Shure: Approximately how many people participated in
Shure:  第一个世界地球日
Shure: the first Earth Day?
Shure:  A 30万
Shure: A. 300,000
Shure:  B 200万
Shure: B. 2 million
Shure:  C 300人
Shure: C. 300 people
Shure:  D  2000万人
Shure: D. 20 million
Alice: 300人
Alice: 300 people.
Shure:  这位同学
Shure: This student,
Shure:  你一直默默无闻
Shure: you have been very quiet.
Shure:  你要不回答一下
Shure: Why don't you answer this one?
Shure:  有人选C了
Shure: Someone chose C.
Shure:  你选什么啊
Shure: What about you?
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  他选第四个
Shure: He chose the fourth one.
Shure:  他们两个选了一个极端
Shure: They picked two extremes.
Shure:  一个选了300人
Shure: One chose 300 people,
Shure:  一个选了2000万人哈哈哈
Shure: and one chose 20 million. Haha.
Shure:  还有不同答案吗
Shure: Any other answers?
Shure:  你看看这个头脑
Shure: Look at this brain.
Alice: 中庸之道
Alice: The middle way.
Shure:  中庸之道对
Shure: The middle way, right.
Shure:  选择了30万还有吗
Shure: Someone chose 300,000. Anyone else?
Shure:  我就知道
Shure: I knew it.
其他人：有没有人是对的
Others: Is anyone correct?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  公布答案
Shure: Announce the answer.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 2000万人
Jake: 20 million.
Alice: 哇这么多人
Alice: Wow, so many people.
Shure:  没有想到吧
Shure: Unexpected, right?
Shure:  就是说明这个日子非常重要
Shure: It shows how important this day is.
Shure:  第一次办就有这么多人参加
Shure: The first event already had so many participants.
Shure:  哪哪位同学选择2000万来着
Shure: Which student chose 20 million?
Shure:  白衣小哥
Shure: The guy in the white shirt.
Shure:  这个这个问题两个币
Shure: This question is worth two coins.
Jake: 这个可以稍作科普
Jake: We can give a little science education here.
Jake: 因为这个世界地球日
Jake: Because it's Earth Day.
Jake: 它主要在高校之间
Jake: Mainly celebrated in universities.
Jake: 高校内进行
Jake: Held within universities.
Jake: 然后高校的那帮人
Jake: And those university folks
Jake: 然后高校的那帮人对都搞得进去
Jake: They really get into it.
Jake: 都搞得进去
Shure:  所以我们有2,000万人参加
Shure: So we have 20 million people participating.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 里边是最最重要的一个活动
Jake: It's one of the most important events.
Shure:  出名的一个
Shure: A famous one.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
Shure:  好的下一题
Shure: Alright, next question.
Shure:  今年的世界地球日的主题是什么
Shure: What's the theme of this year's Earth Day?
Shure:  A投资我们的星球
Shure: A, Invest in Our Planet.
Shure:  B动员地球
Shure: B, Mobilize the Earth.
Shure:  C星球对抗塑料
Shure: C, Planet Versus Plastic.
Shure:  D 10亿绿色行动
Shure: D, A Billion Acts of Green.
Shure:  请抢答
Shure: Please buzz in.
Tasha: 选A
Tasha: Choose A.
Shure:  选A是吗
Shure: Choose A, right?
Shure:  还有不同答案吗
Shure: Any other answers?
Shure:  来C
Shure: Go with C.
Tasha: 4D
Tasha: 4D.
Shure:  4D你你们俩谁先他他他
Shure: 4D, who among you two first? Him, him, him.
Shure:  他你确定
Shure: Are you sure?
Shure:  4D还是让给他
Shure: 4D, or let him answer?
其他人：我2B吧
Other Person: I'll go with 2B.
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  B
Shure: B.
Shure:  D
Shure: D.
Shure:  C
Shure: C.
Shure:  A
Shure: A.
Shure:  然后你是c是吧
Shure: So you're going with C, right?
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay.
CShure:  公布正确答案
Shure: Announcing the correct answer.
Jake:c
Jake: It's C.
Shure:  c选项今年的主题叫做planet versus plastic
Shure: The correct answer is C. This year's theme is "Planet Versus Plastic."
Shure:  就是星球对抗塑料
Shure: That's "Planet Versus Plastic."
Shure:  是我们今年的世界地球日的主题
Shure: It's the theme for this year's Earth Day.
Shure:  然后恭喜
Shure: And congratulations
Shure:  像像这种
Shure: Like this kind of...
其他人：是有过的还是不有过的这种
Others: Is it something that has happened before or not?
Jake: 好问题
Jake: Good question.
Alice: 好问题
Alice: Good question.
Jake: 我们也不知道
Jake: We also don't know.
其他人：这显像是生造出来的还是
Others: Is this something made up or...
Shure:  不不不不
Shure: No, no, no.
Jake: 这所有的题目都是几比几十
Jake: All the questions are like this.
Shure:  这个
Shure: This one...
Shure:  但是答案是保证的
Shure: But the answers are guaranteed.
Tasha: 这也告诉别人
Tasha: Tell others about this.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 这是可以说的吗
Alice: Can we say this?
Shure:  啊没有没有
Shure: Ah, no, no.
Shure:  这个
Shure: This one...
Shure:  其他确实是都没有
Shure: The others really don't have it.
Shure:  没有出现过的都是胡诌出来的
Shure: All the ones that haven't appeared before are made up.
Shure:  然后
Shure: And then...
Shure:  这题三个币
Shure: This question is worth three coins.
Shure:  这怎么还有氛围组呢
Shure: Why do we have a hype team here?
Tasha: 这12块钱到手了
Tasha: This 12 bucks is ours.
Shure:  下一题第7题
Shure: Next question, number 7.
Shure:  地球的南极冰
Shure: The ice in Antarctica...
Shure:  啊地球的南极冰盖
Shure: Ah, the Antarctic ice cap...
Shure:  锁定了多少比百分比的淡水
Shure: How much percentage of the world's freshwater is locked in it?
Shure:  A大约50%
Shure: A. About 50%
Shure:  B大约70%
Shure: B. About 70%
Shure:  C大约90%
Shure: C. About 90%
Shure:  D大约30%
Shure: D. About 30%
Shure:  C
Shure: C
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  2B
Shure: 2B
Jake: 你好啊
Jake: Hello!
Jake: 早上好
Jake: Good morning!
Lucia: B
Katrina:  B
Katrina: B
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  没有其他的选项吗
Shure: Are there no other options?
Shure:  公布答案90
Shure: Reveal the answer, 90.
Jake:90
Jake: 90.
Shure:  90%
Shure: 90%.
Shure:  我们其实世界
Shure: Actually, our world...
Shure:  呃就是地球上最大的淡水资源
Shure: Uh, the largest freshwater resource on Earth...
Shure:  都是南极冰盖锁定的
Shure: is locked in the Antarctic ice sheet.
Shure:  对所以是90%
Shure: So it's 90%.
Shure:  然后这题也三个币子吧
Shure: And for this question, let's give three coins.
Alice: 提问冰盖跟奶盖什么意
Alice: What's the relationship between ice sheets and milk foam?
Alice: 什么关系
Alice: What's the connection?
Shure:  好问题
Shure: Good question.
Jake:好问题
Jake: Good question.
Shure:  就是在我说说你听听
Shure: Let me explain, just listen.
Shure:  在想当初
Shure: Way back in the day,
Shure:  大约3500万年前
Shure: about 35 million years ago,
Lucia: 有百分之五十的子字是一样的
Shure:  女娲补天的时候创造了一个双胞胎
Shure: When Nuwa patched the sky, she created twins.
Shure:  一个叫冰盖一个叫奶盖
Shure: One was called Ice Sheet, the other Milk Foam.
Shure:  对大概就是这么
Shure: Yeah, roughly like that...
其他人：我有一个问题
Others: I have a question.
Jake:唉
Jake: Yes?
其他人：在我印象里它的淡水占72%,但是冰盖是90%
Others: In my impression, fresh water is 72%, but ice sheets are 90%.
其他人：但你这个问是它储存多少淡水而是冰盖有多少水
Others: But the question was about how much freshwater is stored, not how much water the ice sheet has.
其他人：所以你check一下
Others: So you should check it.
Shure:  不是他是就是占
Shure: No, it's about how much of the global freshwater.
Shure:  占了全球淡水的多少
Shure: How much of the global freshwater it contains.
其他人：但是你这个是淡水，90%只是却不是淡水
Others: But you're talking about freshwater, 90% is not just freshwater.
其他人：你可以看一下有没有那个搜一下
Others: You should look it up.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 哎哟
Shure: Oh, man.
Shure:  有人提出了challenge
Shure: Someone's challenging it.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Shure:  直播
Shure: Live search.
Jake: 直播搜索
Jake: Live search.
其他人：已超过这个14后面
Others: It has exceeded 14...
其他人：后面六个零平方公里
Others: followed by six zeros square kilometers.
其他人：厚度达到4公里以上所含的冰量
Others: The thickness reaches over 4 kilometers, containing ice...
其他人：庞大相当于地球所有淡水水量
Others: equivalent to about 70% of all freshwater on Earth.
其他人： 的约70%
Others: About 70%.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
其他人：啊
Others: Ah
Shure:  那
Shure: So
Alice:是水有百分之七十
Alice: Water makes up 70%
Alice:陆地有百分之三十
Alice: Land makes up 30%
Alice:然后是水的
Alice: And then of that water
Alice:百分之七十的水里面有百分之九十的水才是
Alice: 90% of that 70% water is
Alice:嗯 对我理解是这样的
Alice: Yeah, that's how I understand it
小薇 好酷啊
Tasha: So cool
Lucia: 大家好认真
Lucia: Everyone's so serious
Lucia: 没想到
Lucia: Didn't expect that
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yeah
Shure:  那
Shure: So
Alice:对 因为有的水不是淡水
Alice: Right, because some water isn't fresh water
Shure:  转移一下资产
Shure: Transfer some assets
Jake: 转移资产
Jake: Transfer assets
其他人：但我们确定哪 三个是原来的
Others: But which three are the original ones?
其他人：好随便给你什么
Others: Okay, whatever you say
Shure:  然后那我们再奖励一枚币子给
Shure: Then we'll reward a coin to
Shure:  查出正确答案的同学
Shure: The student who finds the correct answer
Shure:  非常的好
Shure: Very good
Shure:  那么下一题
Shure: So the next question
Shure:  地球的南极
Shure: The Earth's South Pole
其他人：哎哎
Others: Hey hey
Shure:  他让我梅开二度的难堪
Shure: It embarrassed me twice
Shure:  从太阳到地球
Shure: From the sun to the Earth
Shure:  阳光需要多长时间到达
Shure: How long does it take for sunlight to reach?
Jake:哎 我去
Jake: Oh, come on
Shure:  这个
Shure: This
Shure:  其实是我们好像高中那种经常算的
Shure: Actually, it's something we often calculated in high school
Shure:  哎呦已经有两位同学举手了
Shure: Wow, already two students raised their hands
Shure:  8分19秒
Shure: 8 minutes and 19 seconds
Shure:  哎呦其实你们两个同时举手
Shure: Wow, you both raised your hands at the same time
Shure:  那你们还有其他答案吗
Shure: Do you have other answers?
其他人：我选B
Others: I choose B
其他人：啊
Others: Ah
Shure: 适合代表人类
Shure: Suitable to represent humanity
Shure:  你知道这个D
Shure: You know this D
Shure:  意味着什么意思吗
Shure: What does it mean?
Shure:  这是我们的表
Shure: This is our chart
Shure:  转了20圈才有一天会看到太阳
Shure: It takes 20 turns to see the sun in a day.
Alice: 确保一定有一个正确答案
Alice: Make sure there is a correct answer.
Alice: 为我们的顺利进行
Alice: For our smooth progress.
Shure:  这这位同学纠正了我的我的错误
Shure: This classmate corrected my mistake.
Shure:  是表转40圈
Shure: It's actually 40 turns.
Shure:  是20圈啊
Shure: It is 20 turns.
Shure:  对对对我疏忽了
Shure: Yes, yes, I was negligent.
Shure:  正确答案就是A
Shure: The correct answer is A.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Shure:  对是8分19秒
Shure: Yes, it's 8 minutes and 19 seconds.
Shure:  大家还记得那个怎么算的了吗
Shure: Do you all remember how to calculate that?
Katrina:  你现在推一遍
Katrina: You explain it again now.
其他人：谁问你了
Others: Who asked you?
其他人：距离除以光速
Others: Distance divided by the speed of light.
Shure:  是是就其实就是这么简单
Shure: Yes, yes, it's actually that simple.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  来
Shure: Come on.
Lucia: 但问题太阳会持续发光
Lucia: But the sun keeps shining.
Lucia: 他又不是歘一下然后又熄灭
Lucia: It's not like it flashes and then goes out.
Shure:  你们你们二位每人两个
Shure: You two each get two.
其他人： 一方面感谢的是这个项目的话如果太阳坏掉了的话
Others: On one hand, this project, if the sun breaks down...
其他人： 也还能
Others: can still...
Lucia: 再活20天
Lucia: survive for another 20 days.
修硕: 很乐观
Shure: Very optimistic.
其他人： 我先看 了8分钟之前
Others: I watched for 8 minutes before.
Jake: 你觉他也不是害人哇
Jake: Do you think he's not harming people?
Katrina:  别把谢斌竹搞懵了
Katrina: Don't confuse Xie Binzhu.
Shure:  下一个问题
Shure: Next question.
Shure:  陨石
Shure: Meteorite.
Shure:  为什么每次都能精准的砸到陨石坑
Shure: Why does it always hit the crater accurately?
Alice: 谁把这个问题加进去了
Alice: Who added this question?
其他人：谁问的这个问题
Others: Who asked this question?
Shure:  这是一个开放型问题
Shure: This is an open-ended question.
Shure:  根据你们的回答我思
Shure: Based on your answers, I think...
Jake: 哈没有更多了
Jake: Ha, there's no more.
Jake: 但是最后有一个问题啊
Jake: But there's one last question.
其他人：也不是说不可以可以
Others: It's not that you can't, you can.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  他的答案非常的好
Shure: His answer is really good.
Katrina:  非常
Katrina: Very.
Lucia:  相似相融
Lucia: Similar and integrated.
Shure:  必须再奖励一个
Shure: He deserves another reward.
Shure:  你现在收获非常
Shure: You've gained a lot now.
Shure:  颇丰
Shure: A lot.
Shure:  再下一个吧
Shure: Next one, please.
Shure:  不孕不育会遗传
Shure: Infertility can be inherited.
Shure:  大家觉得
Shure: What do you all think?
Alice: 这是不是要被逼了
Alice: Are we being forced here?
Lucia: 植物的三倍体是吧
Lucia: Triploid plants, right?
Shure:  二位二位学生
Shure: Two students here.
Shure:  来来来这个是
Shure: Come on, come on, this is...
Shure:  还有一个问题
Shure: There's one more question.
Shure:  那这个是什么
Shure: So what is this?
Jake: 之前
Jake: Before...
Jake: 从0
Jake: From 0...
Jake: 到第14题中间有一个
Jake: To the 14th question, there was one...
Jake: 其实只有13题对
Jake: Actually, there were only 13.
Shure:  对刚刚有一个旗号没有
Shure: Yes, there was one flag missing.
Shure:  大家有发现吗
Shure: Did anyone notice?
Shure:  这是一个彩蛋问题
Shure: This is a bonus question.
Shure:  这个是一个5分的问题
Shure: This is a 5-point question.
其他人：隐藏问题
Others: Hidden question.
Jake: C
Jake: C.
Shure:  这是一个数
Shure: This is a number.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
其他人：那那个重复的是什么题
Others: So what was the repeated question?
Shure:  重复的就是为了迷惑你
Shure: The repeated one was to confuse you.
Shure:  所以他遗漏了啊
Shure: So it was missed, ah.
Shure:  那重复的不算
Shure: The repeated one doesn't count.
Shure:  那个遗漏了哪
Shure: Which one was missed?
Shure:  哪个题号
Shure: Which question number?
Shure:  大家有注意到吗
Shure: Did anyone notice?
其他人：0-13题
Others: Questions 0-13.
Shure:   对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  啊 0-13对0-13
Shure: Uh 0-13, yeah 0-13.
Shure:  他他说7
Shure: He said 7.
Shure:  9
Shure: 9.
Shure:  12
Shure: 12.
Tasha: 这什么东西
Tasha: What's this?
Shure:  这这位同学呢
Shure: This, this classmate...
Shure: 要猜一个没有数字啊
Shure: You have to guess a number that isn't there.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  他猜过了7
Shure: He already guessed 7.
Shure:  他猜过了9
Shure: He already guessed 9.
Shure:  他猜过了12
Shure: He already guessed 12.
Shure:  对0-13里面
Shure: Yeah, within 0-13.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  13就是上一集
Shure: 13 was the last episode.
Jake:看来会赢
Jake: Looks like we might win.
Alice: 老师这种难题
Alice: Teacher, this kind of tough question...
Alice: 我们家刘婷就不参加了
Alice: Our Liu Ting won't participate.
Shure:  猜一个吧
Shure: Just guess one.
Shure:  10
Shure: 10.
Shure:  难难道要要遗落了吗这个
Shure: Is it possible this will be missed?
Shure:  这个给大家缩小一下范围
Shure: Let's narrow it down for everyone.
Shure:  在啊这个数它不是一个质数
Shure: This number is not a prime number.
其他人：  4
Others: 4.
Shure:  继续12
Shure: Keep guessing 12.
小薇  : 11
Tasha: 11.
Tasha: 11
Shure:  7是质数
Shure: 7 is a prime number.
Alice: 不是质数到底在说什么东西啊
Alice: What are you talking about not a prime number?
Shure:  5也是质数
Shure: 5 is also a prime number.
Tasha: 到底在说什么东西啊
Tasha: What are you even talking about?
Tasha: 为什么我能精准地命中这些东西
Tasha: Why can I hit these things accurately?
Tasha: 你们在说什么
Tasha: What are you guys talking about?
Tasha: 1
Tasha: 1.
Alice: 一人猜一个
Alice: Everyone guess one.
Alice: 5是质数哈哈哈哈
Alice: 5 is a prime number, hahaha.
Shure:  5是质数
Shure: 5 is a prime number.
其他人：7年没学过数学了
Others: Haven't studied math in 7 years.
Shure:  请问他坚持是5那我们也没有办法
Shure: If he insists on 5, there's nothing we can do.
Shure:  你你
Shure: You, you...
Shure:  8
Shure: 8
其他人：不是质数 还是是质敉
Other people: Not a prime number, or is it a prime number?
Shure:  不是质数猜一个
Shure: It's not a prime number, just guess one.
Shure:  猜一个猜一个
Shure: Guess one, guess one.
Shure:  给个面给个面
Shure: Give me some face, give me some face.
Shure:  给个面
Shure: Give me some face.
Tasha: 合理呀
Tasha: Sounds reasonable.
Shure:  他掘得我面子
Shure: He disrespected me.
Shure:  我的室友们他掘得我面子
Shure: My roommates disrespected me.
Shure:  好吧好吧
Shure: Okay, okay.
翻翻呗
Someone: Turn it over.
Jake: 翻翻呗
Jake: Turn it over.
Shure:  我我记住了是6
Shure: I remember, it's 6.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 真的
Tasha: Really.
Alice: 没人猜啊
Alice: No one guessed.
Shure:  啊对所以没人猜没人猜
Shure: Ah, right, so no one guessed, no one guessed.
Alice: 嗯 对 6我是
Alice: Hmm, right, 6 is me.
Jake: 确实没人猜啊
Jake: Indeed, no one guessed.
Shure:  所以所以我们这个大奖只能流掉
Shure: So, so this big prize will just go to waste.
Tasha: 到底是几啊
Tasha: What was the number, after all?
Tasha: 是几啊
Tasha: What was the number?
Jake: 6
Jake: 6.
Alice: 6
Alice: 6.
Jake: 6
Jake: 6.
Tasha: 不是有人猜了6
Tasha: Didn't someone guess 6?
Jake: 确实一个人都没猜到99倒是有人猜
Jake: Indeed, no one guessed, but someone guessed 99.
Shure:  那
Shure: Then
Shure:  我们其实就应该到我们的Auction time了
Shure: We should actually move on to our auction time.
Shure:  就是我们的拍卖时间
Shure: It's our auction time.
Shure:  那我们先有请我们的host
Shure: Let's first invite our host.
Shure:  我们的这房间的主人们
Shure: The owners of this room.
Shure:  先来拍一拍东西
Shure: To auction off some items.
Shure:  来掌声
Shure: Give a round of applause.
Shure:  有请第一位
Shure: Let's welcome the first one.
Alice: 不是我还没拿
Alice: Wait, I haven't taken it out yet.
Jake: 我们我们先统计一下币
Jake: Let's first count the coins.
Shure:  大家手上都有多少币吗
Shure: How many coins does everyone have?
Lucia: 有几个了
Lucia: How many do you have?
Tasha: 工作人员为什么没有币
Tasha: Why don't the staff have any coins?
Tasha: 我拍什么东西
Tasha: What am I filming?
Tasha: 不是
Tasha: No
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 那还邀请
Tasha: And still invite
Lucia: 我是不是也得把我的小狗接上来
Lucia: Should I bring my little dog up too?
Alice: 你不是有那个水母灯吗
Alice: Don’t you have that jellyfish lamp?
Katrina:  你们俩一人一只小狗吗
Katrina: Do both of you have a little dog?
Lucia: 水母没有灯珠
Lucia: The jellyfish doesn't have a bulb
Lucia: 它现在不是灯
Lucia: It's not a lamp now
Lucia: 它只是 水母
Lucia: It's just a jellyfish
Alice: 那把狗请上来
Alice: Then bring the dog up
Lucia: 行我去请狗了
Lucia: Okay, I’ll bring the dog
Tasha: 为什么
Tasha: Why
Tasha: 我我不渴
Tasha: I’m not thirsty
Tasha: 我也不渴
Tasha: I'm not thirsty either
Shure:  你回来吧
Shure: You come back
Lucia: 刚进去叠了个被子
Lucia: Just went in to fold a quilt
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 不管是哪一款吧
Tasha: Doesn’t matter which one
Tasha: 反正就没有那个感觉
Tasha: Anyway, it just doesn't feel right
Katrina:  什么
Katrina: What
Tasha: 不是人家
Tasha: No, it’s not
Tasha: 关你屁事
Tasha: None of your business
Tasha: 有帅哥给我介绍
Tasha: There’s a handsome guy introducing me
Katrina:  我还新买了一个手链
Katrina: I also bought a new bracelet
Tasha: 喂
Tasha: Hey
Katrina:  就是那天在那个抖音上买的
Katrina: It’s the one I bought on Douyin that day
Tasha: 有帅哥给我介绍一个
Tasha: There’s a handsome guy introducing me
Lucia: 他可以调的
Lucia: He can adjust it
Lucia: 好像他可以掰开
Lucia: Seems like he can open it
Tasha: 人家人家
Tasha: He, he
Tasha: 人家
Tasha: He
Tasha: 你说
Tasha: You say
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is it
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Shure: 开始 征贺相巾
Shure: Start conquering Xiangjin
Tasha: 长什么样子
Tasha: What does it look like
Jake:呵可以
Jake: Haha, okay
Alice: 什么什么什么
Alice: What, what, what
Shure: 我们统计完自己手上都有多少币了吗
Shure: Have we finished counting how many coins we each have?
Jake: 你干嘛去了
Jake: Where did you go?
Shure:  来来报个数
Shure: Come on, report your numbers.
Katrina:  啥呀
Katrina: What?
Shure:  自己手上有多少币
Shure: How many coins do you have?
Alice: 币
Alice: Coins.
Alice: 20
Alice: 20.
Shure:  那个
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  外外面的场记
Shure: The person keeping track outside.
Shure:  谢斌竹来谢斌竹
Shure: Xie Binzhu, come here.
Shure:  记一下账本
Shure: Write it in the ledger.
Shure:  现在大家手里的币子
Shure: The coins everyone has now.
谢斌竹: 我记
Xie Binzhu: I'll note it.
Shure:  对你记
Shure: Yes, you note it.
Shure:  因为你到时候发钱包
Shure: Because you'll distribute the wallets later.
Katrina:  15
Katrina: 15.
Shure:  呃报一个姓名或者代号
Shure: Uh, report a name or a code.
Katrina:  小杜呗
Katrina: Xiao Du.
Shure:  小杜 小杜有15个币子
Shure: Xiao Du, Xiao Du has 15 coins.
Shure:  小杜小杜小杜
Shure: Xiao Du, Xiao Du, Xiao Du.
Jake: 小杜小杜
Jake: Xiao Du, Xiao Du.
Alice: 小度小度
Alice: Xiao Du, Xiao Du.
Shure:  杜安迪的杜
Shure: Du Andy's Du.
Tasha: 他有15个币
Tasha: He has 15 coins.
Shure:  这位这位同学
Shure: This student.
Shure:  11
Shure: 11.
Nicous:  多少个12
Nicous: How many? 12.
Shure:  十一个才有
Shure: Only 11.
其他人：还有谁
Others: Who else?
其他人： *****68个
Others: ***** 68 coins.
Alice: 你是谁
Alice: Who are you?
Tasha: 小L
Tasha: Xiao L.
Alice: 你也是小L
Alice: You're also Xiao L?
Tasha: 那就
Tasha: Then...
Alice: 你就大L吧XL
Alice: You can be Big L, XL.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你自己先
Tasha: You go first.
Nicous:  这个不行是吧
Nicous: This one is not okay, right?
Lucia: 啊行行
Lucia: Oh, it's okay.
Lucia: 谢谢你
Lucia: Thank you.
Tasha: 我是智性恋你懂吗
Tasha: I'm sapiosexual, you know what that means?
其他人： 智性恋嗯多丑都行
Others: Sapiosexual, huh? Doesn't matter how ugly.
Tasha: 是这样子
Tasha: That's right.
Lucia: 你倒是
Lucia: You, on the other hand...
其他人： 是这样子
Others: That's right.
Tasha: 我是智性恋
Tasha: I'm sapiosexual.
Tasha: 知道什么叫智性恋吗
Tasha: Do you know what sapiosexual means?
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Nicous:  JK
Nicous: Just kidding.
Tasha: JK
Tasha: Just kidding.
Tasha: JK是什么
Tasha: What does "JK" mean?
Shure:  长跑长跑
Shure: Long distance running.
Tasha: 智性恋
Tasha: Sapiosexual.
Shure:  谢斌竹谢斌竹
Shure: Thanks, Binzhu, thanks, Binzhu.
Shure:  记完了吗
Shure: Got it all written down?
其他人：记好了记好了
Others: Yes, all noted down.
Shure:  还有一个那个男的
Shure: There's also that guy.
Shure:  有两个
Shure: There are two of them.
Shure:  主要老板
Shure: Mainly the boss.
Shure:  老板一直盯着我
Shure: The boss keeps staring at me.
Shure:  我这不好不好做事
Shure: It's hard to work this way.
Alice: 暗箱操作
Alice: Under the table deal.
Shure:  来来来你要怎么贿赂我
Shure: Come on, how are you going to bribe me?
Shure:  给你三个吧凑一下五个
Shure: I'll give you three, let's make it five.
Shure:  给你凑一下5个吧
Shure: Let's make it five for you.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright then.
Jake: 好那我们就开始
Jake: Alright, then let's start.
Shure:  好开始先对房间参观
Shure: Okay, let's start by touring the room.
Jake: 先先拍吧
Jake: Let's film first.
Shure:  好那就先拍吧
Shure: Alright, let's film first.
Shure:  把这把这一层的任务大家都做完先
Shure: Let's all finish the tasks on this floor first.
Tasha: 有助于培养
Tasha: It helps to foster...
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 感情
Tasha: Feelings.
Shure:  那我们进入到了激动人心的Auction time
Shure: Now we enter the exciting Auction time.
Shure:  拍卖时间
Shure: Auction time.
Tasha: 算了你身边是不是没有什么
Tasha: Forget it, don't you have anyone around you?
Shure:  下面有请我们的第一位拍品
Shure: Let's welcome our first auction item.
Shure:  不是那个哎呦他怎么断了呢
Shure: Not that one, oh no, why did it cut off?
Shure:  老板你干什么呢老板
Shure: Boss, what are you doing, boss?
Tasha: 智性恋啊
Tasha: Sapiosexual, huh?
Nicous:  这个绝对智性
Nicous: This is definitely sapiosexual.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Tasha: 什么学校的
Tasha: Which school?
Tasha: 什么学历的
Tasha: What's their education level?
Tasha: 真的很聪明吗
Tasha: Are they really smart?
Tasha: 你你学弟
Tasha: Your junior?
Lucia: 他没有灯
Lucia: He doesn't have a light.
Lucia: 而且我的那个欧根纱
Lucia: And my organza...
Lucia: 我发现贴到墙上之后就不好再剪了
Lucia: I found that once it's stuck to the wall, it's hard to cut.
Lucia: 所以我就光大概做了一下
Lucia: So I just roughly did it.
Tasha: 身体非常好
Tasha: His health is really good.
Lucia: 理论上说里面应该有一个灯珠
Lucia: Theoretically, there should be a light bulb inside.
Lucia: 真的吗
Lucia: Really?
Lucia: 但是它没有
Lucia: But there isn't.
Shure:  好的好的
Shure: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 正的
Tasha: Really.
Lucia: 对而且我没有热胶枪
Lucia: And I don't have a hot glue gun.
Tasha: 性格嘞
Tasha: What about personality?
Shure:  第一位拍卖的同学
Shure: The first item up for auction.
Lucia: 这个这个角我是粘住的
Lucia: This corner is glued.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 但是这个没粘住
Lucia: But this part isn't.
Tasha: 我怎么加人家啊
Tasha: How do I add them?
Shure:  来介绍一下自己的拍品
Shure: Introduce your auction item.
Shure:  就Lucia先来吧
Shure: Let's have Lucia go first.
Tasha: 我不知道在长什么样啊
Tasha: I don't know what they look like.
Lucia: 我来嘛
Lucia: I'll do it.
Lucia: 好吧稍等一下
Lucia: Okay, just a moment.
Tasha: 那可以啊
Tasha: That works.
Lucia: 那我就还是用这个小狗吧
Lucia: Then I'll just use this little dog.
Lucia: 如果如果我在接下来的
Lucia: If I, if in the next...
Lucia: 如果我在接下来的5分钟之内
Lucia: If in the next 5 minutes...
Lucia: 把那个水母修好了
Lucia: I fix the jellyfish...
Lucia: 我就我就再我就再来一轮
Lucia: I'll go for another round.
Lucia: 就是现在
Lucia: Starting now.
Tasha: 那不行
Tasha: No way.
Lucia: 我就只能用这只小狗了
Lucia: I can only use this little dog.
Tasha: 哪里行了
Tasha: How is that okay?
Lucia: 对它是一个纸箱小狗
Lucia: Yeah, it's a cardboard puppy.
Tasha: 你找的是不是都是大学生本科的
Tasha: Are you only looking for college students with a bachelor's degree?
Lucia: 然后本来是做好
Lucia: And originally it was made to be
Lucia: 是为了放在我们这个房子的一楼门口
Lucia: placed at the entrance of our house on the first floor.
Tasha: 不是那人家比我小我怎么好意思呢
Tasha: No, they're younger than me, how could I be okay with that?
Lucia: 然后左右各一个就相当于一个石狮子
Lucia: And one on each side, like stone lions.
Lucia: 不过它只是一只纸狗
Lucia: But it's just a paper dog.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 然后因为因为我的水母灯
Lucia: And because my jellyfish lamp
Lucia: 他因为一些状况
Lucia: due to some issues
Lucia: 他没有灯珠
Lucia: doesn't have light bulbs.
Lucia: 并且就是这个腿没有粘稳
Lucia: And its legs aren't stable.
Tasha: 那你那你
Tasha: So you, you...
Lucia: 所以我决定
Lucia: So I decided
Tasha: 弟弟不好
Tasha: Your brother is not good.
Lucia: 先用这个小狗来代替它的位置
Lucia: to use this little dog to replace it for now.
Lucia: 然后如果有喜欢它的朋友们
Lucia: And if any friends like it,
Jake:有水吗这
Jake: Is there water here?
Tasha: 那你不结婚吗
Tasha: Aren't you getting married?
Lucia: 就可以尝试出一下价
Lucia: they can try to make an offer.
Tasha:  人家不着急
Tasha: They're not in a hurry.
Jake:没杯子啊
Jake: No cups?
Lucia: 好像没有什么其它可介绍的
Lucia: Seems like there's nothing else to introduce.
Lucia: 要不先这样
Lucia: How about we stop here for now?
Tasha: 是啊我我有一点
Tasha: Yeah, I, I have a little...
Shure:  呃对
Shure: Uh, yeah.
Tasha: 我妈让我研究生毕业
Tasha: My mom wants me to finish my master's degree.
Shure:  这个Lucia同学的这个拍品
Shure: This item from Lucia
Shure:  就是可能和我们的这个
Shure: is probably related to our
Shure:  ego life的主题比较相关
Shure: ego life theme.
Shure:  就是
Shure: So...
Shure:  它是用我们这两天拆的
Shure: It's made from the boxes
Shure:  快递的一些箱子
Shure: from the deliveries we received these past few days.
Shure:  做的一些小的手工品
Shure: It's some small crafts.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Shure:  还是比较环保比较一口的对起拍价
Shure: It's quite eco-friendly, and the starting bid is one coin.
Shure:  一个一个一个币
Shure: One, one, one coin.
Shure:  哪位同学
Shure: Anyone interested?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  我们的小杜出来一个币子
Shure: Our little Du just put out one coin.
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What is it?
Alice: 拍卖呢
Alice: It's an auction.
Lucia: 现在开始拍卖了
Lucia: The auction is starting now.
Shure:  我们的
Shure: Our...
Shure:  刚才他他叫什么来着
Shure: What was his name again?
Jake: 黄儿
Jake: Huang.
Shure:  黄导是吗
Shure: Director Huang, right?
Alice: 黄儿
Alice: Huang.
Shure: 黄导是吗
Shure: Director Huang, right?
Jake:小H
Jake: Little H.
Shure:  啊黄导出了两个币子
Shure: Ah, Director Huang put out two coins.
Shure:  还有更高的吗
Shure: Any higher bids?
Shure:  两个币子一次
Shure: Two coins, going once.
Shure:  两个币子两次两个币子三次
Shure: Two coins, going twice, two coins, going three times.
Shure:  成交
Shure: Sold!
Lucia: 哪哪哪位同学来着
Lucia: Which student was it?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  现在交换你的两个
Shure: Now exchange your two...
Nicous:  那我要记吗
Nicous: Do I need to remember?
Jake: 你要记了
Jake: You need to remember it.
Shure:  要记要记
Tasha: 小h给了Lucia
Tasha: Little H gave them to Lucia.
Jake:给LUCIA
Jake: To Lucia.
Lucia: 都给我了
Lucia: All to me?
Shure:  好的 全部转移了
Shure: Alright, everything has been transferred.
Shure:  全部转移了
Shure: Everything has been transferred.
Shure:  Lucia现在是两个币子
Shure: Lucia now has two coins.
Shure:  这不是两个好像是他身上所有的
Shure: Wait, it's not just two, it's all the coins he had.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 两个
Lucia: Two.
Jake: 两个
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two.
Alice: 两个
Alice: Two.
Lucia: 这不刚开始吗
Lucia: Isn't this just the beginning?
Nicous:  你卖什么
Nicous: What are you selling?
Shure:  那我们
Shure: Then we...
Tasha: 我卖什么
Tasha: What am I selling?
Shure:  下面有请
Shure: Next, let's welcome...
Tasha: 你要买吗
Tasha: Do you want to buy it?
Shure:  第二个拍品
Shure: The second auction item.
Tasha: 我送你一个
Tasha: I'll give you one.
Tasha: 你送给你女朋友
Tasha: You can give it to your girlfriend.
Lucia: 我去我的压花还没拆
Lucia: Oh no, I haven't even unpacked my pressed flowers yet.
Tasha: 送你一个我拿出来
Tasha: I'll give you one, let me take it out.
Tasha: 接下来拍啥
Tasha: What's next for the auction?
Shure:  拍
Shure: Auction.
Katrina:  我们刚开始的时候
Katrina: When we first started,
Katrina:  原来每人买一束鲜花
Katrina: everyone would buy a bunch of fresh flowers.
Katrina:  然后换花瓶养
Katrina: Then we'd put them in vases.
Katrina:  然后买的是那个呃白百合和黄的百合
Katrina: We bought white lilies and yellow lilies.
Katrina:  还有那个康乃馨和芍药
Katrina: Also, carnations and peonies.
Katrina:  就都会自已种的
Katrina: All self-grown.
Katrina:  然后就慢慢开了
Katrina: And they slowly bloomed.
Katrina:  以后我们就把它放在压花器里压
Katrina: Then we would put them in the flower pressers.
Katrina:  压两三天以后
Katrina: After two or three days,
Katrina:  晒干以后给大家做成这种书签
Katrina: we dried them and made bookmarks for everyone.
Katrina:  就是对
Katrina: Exactly.
Katrina:  就可以放书里面
Katrina: You can put them in books.
Katrina:  然后调料的话还是挺香的
Katrina: And they still smell pretty good.
Katrina:  然后还有这种明信片
Katrina: Also, there's these postcards.
Katrina:  就是明片的话就是会少一点
Katrina: Though we made fewer postcards.
Katrina:  就是放了一些花瓣这些然后就长这个样子
Katrina: We put some petals on them, and they look like this.
其他人：大家拍一下
Others: Everyone, take a photo.
其他人： 起拍价
Others: Starting price.
Lucia:  那就是 2个就1EGO币起拍
Lucia: Two of them start at 1 EGO coin.
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  一份明信片加
Shure: One postcard plus
Katrina:  一个书签
Katrina: One bookmark.
Shure:  一个书签
Shure: One bookmark.
Shure:  你你这个样有点多
Shure: You, you have quite a lot here.
Tasha: 之前不是说了吗那个种子纸你知道吗
Tasha: Didn't we say before about that seed paper?
Shure:  要不我们重新定一下价呢
Shure: How about we adjust the price?
Jake:等会儿吃等会儿吃
Jake: Wait a moment, let's eat later.
Tasha: 嗯每个都有
Tasha: Yeah, each one has it.
Shure:  那我们就是
Shure: So we...
Shure:  四个四个来
Shure: Four of them, four of them.
Shure:  2+2 好吧
Shure: 2+2, okay?
Tasha: 然后把这个纸你看
Tasha: And this paper, you see.
Lucia: 你看 撕碎之后 送在土壤里面
Lucia: You see, tear it up and put it in the soil.
Tasha: 撕碎放在土壤里面就可以发芽
Tasha: Tear it up and put it in the soil, it will sprout.
Shure:  两个书签加两个明信片
Shure: Two bookmarks and two postcards.
Tasha: 对自己设计的
Tasha: Yes, I designed them myself.
Shure:  起拍价
Shure: Starting price.
Tasha: 怎么样
Tasha: How about it?
Shure:  一个ego币懂了吗
Shure: One ego coin, got it?
Tasha: 懂了吗
Tasha: Got it?
Tasha: 懂了稍微
Tasha: Got it, sort of.
Tasha: 等会帮我介绍一下
Tasha: Help me introduce it later.
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two.
Tasha: 行吗
Tasha: Okay?
Tasha: 是送你一个
Tasha: I'll give you one.
Shure:  这个非常激激烈啊
Shure: This is very intense.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  两个一次
Shure: Two at a time.
Tasha: 我让你送给女朋友没让你捣乱
Tasha: I told you to give it to your girlfriend, not to mess around.
Shure:  三个
Shure: Three.
其他人： 哦哦很多组啊多组啊那得4那得4
Others: Oh, a lot of sets, a lot of sets, that makes 4.
其他人：我们一个人一个不就行了吗
Others: Can't we just each get one?
其他人： 哦哦那得4那得4
Others: Oh, that makes 4.
Shure:  落子无悔啊落子无悔
Shure: No regrets once you place the bid.
Tasha: 我的定价是一个ego币一个
Tasha: My price is one ego coin each.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure:  三个一次三个两次三个三次
Shure: Three once, three twice, three thrice.
Tasha: 太贵了
Tasha: Too expensive.
Tasha: 一个ego币一个
Tasha: One ego coin each.
Jake: 自己人后台无价
Jake: For our own folks, it's priceless backstage.
Shure:  成交
Shure: Deal.
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  我们第一组书签加明信片
Shure: Our first set, bookmarks and postcards.
Tasha: 你跟他说一个ego币一个
Tasha: Tell him it's one ego coin each.
其他人： 你先不要着急，我先把钱攒够的
Others: Don't rush, let me save enough money first.
Tasha: 6个打包5个ego币起卖
Tasha: Six for a package, starting at five ego coins.
Tasha: 算了6个
Tasha: Never mind, six.
Jake: 还贷款拍卖
Jake: Auctioning off loans.
其他人： 我的钱去哪儿了
Others: Where did my money go?
其他人： 这是自己藏的吗
Others: Did you hide it yourself?
其他人： 自己藏自己找是吧
Others: Hiding it and finding it yourself, right?
Jake: 自藏自讨
Jake: Hide and seek with yourself.
其他人：我去找它我藏的
Others: I'll go find what I hid.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Shure:  这是第一组
Shure: This is the first group
Shure:  第二组起拍
Shure: Second group, start bidding
Shure:  还有两还有两组啊
Shure: There are two more groups, two more groups
Jake:找不到了
Jake: Can't find it
其他人： 找到了
Others: Found it
Jake:恩
Jake: Yeah
Shure:  起拍价一
Shure: Starting bid one
Shure:  一个
Shure: One
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two
Shure:  两个一次
Shure: Two once
Shure:  两个两次
Shure: Two twice
Tasha: 你一定要好好介绍
Tasha: You have to introduce it well
Tasha: 你要说他要是种下去
Tasha: You need to say if they plant it
Shure:  三个一次
Shure: Three once
Shure:  还有人要加价吗
Shure: Anyone want to raise the bid?
Shure:  四个哎呦
Shure: Four, oh wow
Jake: 啊这么有钱
Jake: Ah, so rich
其他人： 我有150个
Others: I have 150
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  账本不算啊
Shure: Accounts don't count
Nicous:  我有四个
Nicous: I have four
Shure:  他就想想四个来吧
Shure: He just wants to try with four
Shure:  那4个一次 4个两次
Shure: Then four once, four twice
Shure:  4个两次
Shure: Four twice
其他人： 我操没人扛价了
Others: Damn, no one is raising the bid
Shure:  so
Shure: So
Shure:  4个三次
Shure: Four three times
Katrina:  好
Katrina: Okay
Katrina:  谢谢老板
Katrina: Thanks boss
Shure:  记好账啊记好账
Shure: Keep good records, keep good records
Shure:  那剩下这些就一一起出来一次
Shure: Then the remaining ones will come out together once
其他人： 还我吧破产
Others: Give it back, I'm broke
Tasha: 等我把我的东西卖了我替你还上债
Tasha: Once I sell my stuff, I'll pay off your debt
Tasha: 爹
Tasha: Dad
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay
其他人：该我几个
Others: How many do I have?
Shure:  不是币子币子币子
Shure: Not coins, coins, coins
Katrina:  我币吗
Katrina: My coins?
Katrina:  我现在是五个加四个等于十个
Katrina: Now I have five plus four, that's ten
Shure:  可以贷款
Shure: You can take a loan.
Lucia: 你不是150个吗
Lucia: Aren't you supposed to have 150?
Shure:  然后刚刚
Shure: And just now...
Shure:  他们两位的
Shure: For the two of them...
Shure:  还是他们两位
Shure: Or maybe for the two of them...
Shure:  他们三位
Shure: The three of them...
Shure:  每人是
Shure: Each person...
Shure:  减了3你减了
Shure: Reduced by 3, you reduced...
Shure:  还还有谁划了三个
Shure: Who else reduced by three?
Shure:  他3
Shure: Him, 3...
Shure:  他
Shure: Him...
Shure:  黄导黄导
Shure: Director Huang, Director Huang...
Shure:  就他没变
Shure: He didn't change.
Shure:  他没变还是9
Shure: He didn't change, still 9.
其他人：   这两个也没变
Others: These two didn't change either.
Katrina:  你们三都没花出去钱
Katrina: None of you three spent any money.
其他人： 对呀 这一轮没花出去
Others: Yeah, this round no one spent.
Shure:  非常可惜
Shure: Such a pity.
Shure:  那个请那个场务人员不要哄抬物价啊
Shure: Please, the staff, don't inflate the prices.
Shure:  来吧下一位拍卖者
Shure: Alright, next auctioneer.
Shure:  welcome any host animal
Shure: Welcome any host animal.
Shure:  你上吧
Shure: Your turn.
Alice: 我来吧
Alice: I'll go.
Tasha: 不是你上吧 啊上 你先上
Tasha: Not you, go ahead, you go first.
Tasha: 啊上你先上
Tasha: Yeah, you go first.
Tasha: 哄抬一下价格
Tasha: Raise the price a bit.
Lucia: 我的我的CP
Lucia: My, my CP.
Lucia: 我的CP来了
Lucia: My CP is here.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Nicous:  待会找一下他照片
Nicous: Find his picture later.
Shure:  这是
Shure: This is...
Tasha: 等我抬到两个
Tasha: Let me raise it to two.
Alice: Lucia的CP狗
Alice: Lucia's CP dog.
Shure:  他叫二狗
Shure: His name is Er Gou.
Alice: Lucia狗的CP狗
Alice: Lucia's CP dog.
Tasha: 等他出三个我就分你一个
Tasha: When he gets three, I'll give you one.
Lucia: 突然打人
Lucia: Suddenly hits people.
Tasha: 我拿两
Tasha: I'll take two.
Tasha: 怎么样
Tasha: How about that?
Alice: 大家可以叫他二哈
Alice: Everyone can call him Er Ha.
Alice: 啊其实我本来准备的是水仙种子
Alice: Ah, actually I had prepared some narcissus seeds.
Alice: 但是我P的太狠了
Alice: But I edited the photo too hard.
Alice: 我忘买了
Alice: I forgot to buy them.
Alice: 然后就做了一只纸狗
Alice: So I made a paper dog instead.
Alice: 然后这个纸狗的话赠送一个卫生纸
Alice: And this paper dog comes with a roll of toilet paper.
Alice: 捏的花已经别到他的耳朵上了
Alice: The flower I made is already pinned to its ear.
Alice: 好就这样
Alice: That's it.
Alice: 起拍价一个
Alice: Starting bid is one.
Alice: 大家不用哄抬
Alice: No need to bid high.
Alice: 因为我还会捏
Alice: Because I can make more.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 一个起拍
Alice: Starting bid is one.
Shure:  一个一次
Shure: One, once.
其他人：就到此为止吧
Others: Let's stop here.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  一个两次
Shure: One, twice.
Shure:  这可比Lucia多一朵花呀
Shure: This has one more flower than Lucia's.
小薇硕: 哄抬一下
Tasha: Bid higher.
Shure:  那我们
Shure: So we...
Tasha: 我赚到的我帮你还
Tasha: I'll repay what I earn.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure:  哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh wow, oh wow.
Tasha: 我说哄抬我的
Tasha: I said bid higher for mine.
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two.
Jake: 哪来的钱哈
Jake: Where's the money coming from, huh?
其他人：我我我受到了受到了我受到了蒙骗
Others: I, I, I feel deceived.
其他人： 我我我我退出拍卖了我已经
Others: I'm, I'm, I'm out of the auction, I'm done.
其他人：   我退出拍卖
Others: I'm out of the auction.
Shure:  那就还是一个
Shure: So it's back to one.
Katrina: 起拍价卖他了给
Katrina: Sell it at the starting bid.
Shure:  so
Shure: So...
Tasha: 上
Tasha: Let's go.
Shure:  有没有敲的这么响一点的东西
Shure: Is there something we can knock louder?
Tasha: 吐4块钱我帮你还了
Tasha: I'll repay you the 4 bucks.
Alice: 给你留着吧
Alice: You keep it.
Alice: 你多买点
Alice: Buy more.
Nicous:  你得粘上啊
Nicous: You need to stick it.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 你这样你去就行了
Tasha: Just go like this.
其他人： 我来卖东西了
Others: I'm here to sell things.
其他人：你什么时候出来的
Others: When did you come out?
其他人： 我可以和代购
Others: Can I do purchasing on behalf of others?
其他人：我是代购
Others: I do purchasing on behalf of others.
Nicous:  这个是我姐说的
Nicous: This is what my sister said.
Jake: 想一下怎么变
Jake: Think about how to change it.
其他人： 就这么说吧这个东西从主题上说
Others: Let's say, from the theme perspective...
其他人：他是一个很环保的手制书签
Others: It's a very eco-friendly handmade bookmark.
其他人： 然后你们把这个东西
Others: And then you guys...
其他人： 倒在倒在那个土壤里
Others: Pour it into the soil.
其他人：浇水太阳能生成种子
Others: Water it and sunlight will generate seeds.
Tasha: 生成太阳花
Tasha: It will grow sunflowers.
其他人：太阳花上面的实际价值
Others: The actual value of the sunflower.
其他人：它上面的实际价值就非常屌
Others: The actual value on it is very impressive.
其他人： 你们买了这个就和我姐建立了联系
Others: If you buy this, you will connect with my sister.
其他人： 你们只要认识了她 你们就能一帆风顺
Others: Once you know her, everything will go smoothly for you.
其他人： 一个起拍      1go 币起拍
Others: Starting bid, 1 ego coin.
Shure:  你这不行
Shure: This won't work.
Shure:  市场监督管理局提醒您
Shure: The Market Supervision Administration reminds you.
Shure:  你这总共有几个
Shure: How many do you have in total?
其他人： 总共6个
Others: There are 6 in total.
Shure:  6个总共6个
Shure: 6, 6 in total.
Shure:  两个一个吧
Shure: Two per pack, okay?
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  我们不希望东西它不是成对出现的
Shure: We don't want things to appear alone, right? It's so lonely.
Shure:  对吧多孤独啊
Shure: Right?
Shure:  好的那我们一ego币
Shure: Okay, one ego coin.
Shure:  两个种子包
Shure: Two seed packs.
Shure:  可以吗
Shure: Is that okay?
Shure:  起拍二
Shure: Starting bid, two.
其他人： 走一下流程是吗
Others: Follow the process, right?
Shure:  两个还有更高的吗
Shure: Two, any higher bids?
Shure:  两个依次
Shure: Two once.
Shure:  哎呦黄导还是大气
Shure: Oh wow, Director Huang is generous.
Shure:  三个三个一次
Shure: Three, three once.
Shure:  还有人要加价吗
Shure: Any higher bids?
Shure:  三个两次
Shure: Three twice.
Shure:  三个三次成交
Shure: Three times, sold.
Shure:  好的
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  第二轮拍卖
Shure: Second round of bidding.
Shure:  一一个起拍
Shure: Starting bid, one.
Shure:  两个二两个一次
Shure: Two at two once.
Shure:  两个两次
Shure: Two at two twice.
Shure:  两个3次
Shure: Two at three times.
Shure:  成交
Shure: Sold.
其他人：最后一个
Others: The last one.
Shure:  啊还有最后一份
Shure: Ah, there's one more left.
Shure:  两个一次
Shure: Two at once.
Shure:  还有出更高的吗
Shure: Any higher bids?
Shure:  两个两次
Shure: Two at twice.
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two.
Shure:  还有还有出价的吗
Shure: Any more bids?
其他人： 三次
Others: Three times.